attention
from paralympian to para astronaut it
has been quite a journey for John McFall
he lost part of a leg in a motorbike
accident won the 100 meters Bronze in
Beijing and is now the world's first
disabled astronaut testing the
feasibility of working on the
International Space Station but when you
look at really the fine detail of what
you're required to do in microgravity
there are you you use your limbs in
different ways so the real answer is we
don't know whether being an amputee is a
benefit or a disadvantage and do you
wear a prosthesis or do you not wear a
prosthesis so this is the whole reason
why we're doing this feasibility project
is to work those sorts of things out two
others from the UK were among the
successful astronauts taken on by the
European Space Agency almost 23 000
people applied Megan and Christian will
join the reserves Rosemary Coogan is one
of five to start training in Germany
next year for a future Mission perhaps
to the Moon it would be absolutely
incredible we haven't had a European on
the moon and I think that's going to
mean so much both to me and hopefully to
the whole of Europe to see that happen
to see the European leadership and
autonomy increase and to achieve that
and it will Esa made a big push for
diversity half the intake of women but
they're still all white and the space
agency will look at why people from
ethnic minority backgrounds aren't
making it through the selection process
Britain science Minister said the
inclusion of a disabled astronaut showed
space could be for all I think for many
people in Britain the highlight of the
last
10 so years was the Olympics London 2012
and for many people the Paralympics was
perhaps even more inspiring than the
normal Olympics because it showed the
Triumph of the human Spirit against uh
the obstacles of life and that's the
stuff that drives people to do
extraordinary things NASA's Orion
spacecraft is now orbiting the moon on a
test flight for landing humans on the
surface three Europeans will be given
seats this decade there is always huge
excitement about the selection of new
astronauts the rest of us don't stand
much chance of making the grade but
through them we can be Spellbound by
space exploration
the Moon is just a stepping stone
Europe's new astronaut trainees are
walking on air today perhaps on Mars
tomorrow Thomas More Sky News in Paris